and the hour has pretty much arrived
I'll wait I'll wait another minute for
the for the remainder of the peak of
course you can't tell it's not like the
murmur subsides because we can't really
hear the murmur not yet anyway the chats
and the q and A's haven't started yet
good evening good afternoon good morning
did everything to to the world of
quantum devices this is the last session
of the quantum devices workshop of the
Simons Institute of the quantum waves
program for computing and I'm pleased to
chair the next two presentations by
distinguished physical theorists who are
who work on well innovative modeling of
superconducting devices and have been
are studying different aspects of how
they can be brought to a new world we've
heard quite a bit this week about how
existing quantum superconducting devices
are already influencing our world of
quantum computing so let me begin by
introducing Alexander Bley professor of
physics at Shahrukh at university of
sherbrooke and director of the institute
Quantic there and he will give us a
lecture on quantum computing with
stabilized cap qubits Alexander take it
away I think you David thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak at
this conference and for the Simon
Institute for nothing to the new
situation so rapidly
so indeed so today I'm going to talk
about Coulomb competing with sterilized
cat qubits this is work which was
decided by Yuri
when she was a postdoc at shabak and she
has continued to play that role now that
she's a postdoc yeah so since the topic
of my talk is qubits beyond the transmat
qubits beyond the current
standard super taking it I thought I
would take the opportunity to say also a
few words about some new results that
were updating in collaboration with the
entity history on the zero PI cubic inch
of work and that work was led by I guess
did so we've heard about sorting quantum
processor already during this week but
it's a few words about again the basics
of how they work before moving on to are
we going to try to improve them so today
all of those stupid we're going to think
on the processor is that that are being
studied share a few will share many
ingredients to start with all of them or
most of them are based on so-called
transmen qubits which I resent by simple
two-level systems and all of these
transform units can be individually
controlled with microwave also to
realize expiring circuits and then to
make these cuban interact or to read out
these qubits you embed them in a
microwave cavity represented here by the
two mirrors and so this cavity plays
medium roles first you can send a
microwave tone at the input point of the
ket and collect what comes out and that
informated microwave tone coming out of
the cavity
well in fact carry information about the
states of the qubits which are inside a
cavity therefore allowing you to do in
cuba Treena more awareness he can be
used as a form of quantum bus to mediate
interaction mediate entanglement between
different qubits for example if you
could read some interesting states of
your first unit then you can transfer
this like this this state to a microwave
photon to an excitation of the cavity
filled and this excitation can be a
rehab stored by the qubit which doesn't
have to be any rest
cubed and in this way you are able to
entangle the different qubits okay so
the transplants are a bit some type of
microwave cavity which allows you to do
readout and gates so that's what
variation on spirit a quantum processor
another variation is a little bit more
like this and this is what we've heard
from the google group earlier this week
and it is particularly ionization what
they do is they again use transform
qubits which are again read out by
microwave resonator but rather than
using cavities to mediate interaction
these qubits are coupled through some
other couplers in that particular case
these couplers are in fact other types
of transport qubits okay so that's the
state of things in static quantum
processors and of course by now we can
scale this to several tens of q vs m and
operate them quietly to do interesting
computations but of course as we scale
up we it's important that we look at the
next challenge for the field and that
next challenge I think we can all agree
is quantum error correction how do we
bring in quantum error correction
because simply Bruce for scaling these
devices is probably not the solution and
this is where it's getting a little bit
scary when you think about what quantum
error correction means it requires for
example if you are interested in
factoring your number
this will take something like a thousand
logical qubits and if you encode these
logical qubits in the surface covered
using a surface code that may mean that
you need something somewhere something
like 10 to the 6 or 10 to the 9 physical
qubits
that's quite a dumb thing that's of
course quite challenging and so what
that means is that we need we need
better physical qubits we need to
improve
the quality of these qubits to make sure
that I mean the woman that is required
is not too large and osco improve the
cost in cells the surface code is quite
interesting it's a great pad for at the
moment it might not be the solution it
might be the they don't only approach
okay so if we want to think about
improving upon the qubits it's important
to look at what is the correct standard
qubits and that's the transmen qubit
which is used again by Google IBM and
many academic groups of course
and so the transplant qubit looks
something like this so it's simply a
Josephson junction which is shunted by a
large capacitor and so it looks
something like this if you take an
update optical image this is just one
type of realization of that's one qubits
you will see the literature transform
keep it looking very differently than
that but they share the same comments
simple circuit so this circuit has
several advantages this is why it is
being used so widely and one of these is
that it has pretty good clearance times
its consequence time are relatively long
and so if you look at the evolution of
these transmen like qubits over the
years in green that they're t2 time or
if you are typical type for a phaser it
worker and then blue and blue the t1
time or if you walk the time the typical
type for a face flip a bit flicker to
occur these times I've increased quite
dramatically since the first experiment
by as-sunnah camera in 1999 where these
times were served nanoseconds in fact
it's quite interesting I think to plug
this analog scale where you see the
brilliance what do we connect my iPad
you see okay
okay so I've lost my nice pointer no
problem so you see here the there is
some interesting rate of improvement of
these qubits over the years but okay of
course it'll ask you much we've been
looking too much at exponential curves
so let's not dwell too much on this
anymore I will rather say that the
transman cubed is interesting also
because it almost always work safety
works you build them and they work and
so we know for example from the google
work the chip really had 54 cubed but
only 53 of them was working one was not
working what we've learned in Monday's
talk is that this that the problem was
not with a transman keep it at Southwest
whitson some external connection to that
trans mom so you can build several tens
of these transplant qubits and they will
simply work there also of course also
quite simple just a junction shunted by
a capacitor
okay but that being said so in these
disadvantages explain why the transfer
is being used so widely but what we've
seen over the last 20 years is some kind
of what you could call qubit Darwinism
where initially it was several types of
Superman qubits that were study and now
we've seen a strong focus on the
transplant and so this has certainly led
to improvement in the short term and in
the mid term and this is what we are
really seeing here so this is really the
effort of of several groups word while
allowing for these improvements but
maybe by focusing so much on a single
type of qubit we might have lost some
advantages in the long term because
maybe the transplant is not the final
Cuba that will be used in a quantum
computer so transplant might not be
enough and we've seen recently a
resurgence of different types of more
exotic qubit for example a flock Sonya
of the zero piety and the boson they
give it for the cat code qubits which I
will speak more about today but before
you go into the boson a qubit let me say
a few words only about the zero point
so the co-op I pivot is quite an
interesting device I would say this is
one of these candidates that idea of the
transplant and so this was first
introduced by Ikeda ever been studied
most closely by Brooks Keita EV and
press Kalyan and 2013 and so this is
what it looks like so yeah again
capacitors junctions and now in addition
inductors and you if you look at this
device in your ring for the moment the
inductance you see something like looks
like a transplant so this is your bike
event there's a transplant like cuba
transmen life degree of freedom now if
you in your rather the capacitances you
see a loop and for some of you that will
remind you of a flux qubit or more
precisely here something i would call a
light flux oh no keep it
and so really in the zero PI qubit
there's different species of qubits that
are hidden there's different degrees of
freedom and because you have these
different degrees of freedom you can
optimize the you have more degree you
have more flexibility in optimizing the
system such that you can find primary
regimes where T 1 and P 2 the error
rates there are the typical times for
errors to occur so deceiveth are
exponentially suppressed that's quite
interesting because what we know is that
in simpler devices that have a single
that we are freedom such as a transplant
or the flux Anyang by themself I'm
thinking like this would not be possible
but that comes at the price I mean this
this device is challenging to realize
for example these inductances are not
made of simply small wires but are made
of arrays of Josephson junctions that
can have hundreds of junctions something
like 200 200 Josephson junctions
moreover because the qubit is protected
against errors it's also in a sense
protected against gates it can be
difficult to enact logical gates between
two protected states and if you want to
learn more about this I graduate to look
at these papers by I guess in the other
one and comics where we have looked at
these questions
so quite recently this gibbet was now
realized in the group of rock grayscale
Princeton where so this is a picture of
what it looks like where you see
Josephson junctions and these thick
wires which are the super inductance is
made out of hundreds of Josephson
junctions and so for this very first
device what we have observed is t1 and
t2 times that are quite good in fact
that t1 time for this very first to
apply device is that so it as one point
five milliseconds that's an order of
magnitude larger than your typical best
transplant and the T to time is not as
impressive but is still very respectable
26 microsecond that's important to
understand that this is a first device
that's a first realization of these
ideas we're attempted to to compare
these numbers to the best friend's moms
that are out there but we have to
remember that these transplants have are
the results of more than a decade of
improvements by tens of groups if the
first friend found that such impressive
results that would have been quite
something
so we're quite lucky with these results
I mean we think that the zero pie keep
it is very promising okay so Travis the
CEO of mine cubed is one of the
candidate to give better physical qubits
let me now introduce another type of
super high-tech qubits that could play
this role and that will tie in now it
also better codes that's the concept of
cap qubits or those anecdotes so what
we've come to understand as a field now
is that codes are quantum error
correcting codes are central to cannot
copy date architectures most common
computers where code of computers will
spend probably most of their clock
cycles actually doing quantum error
correction so while at the moment most
of their error correcting codes
then develop without thinking too much
about the hardware it's probably time
that we start developing codes with the
specific hardware in mind and that's the
general concept of hardware efficient
quantum error correction which is
getting more and more attraction field
so are very efficient quantum error
correction should be contrasted to
generic error correction where you take
a bunch of physical qubits here in
behind physical qubits and you encode a
single logical qubits so your encode
logical qubits in there's subspace of
logic multiple physical qubits and again
typically there's no assumptions about
the other lying hardware so there might
be some errors that are unlike unlikely
for example linear hardware that you
might be correcting with your code and
as a result you might be using too many
physical qubits you might be using a
larger overhead that's strictly
necessary
so here comes this concept of hardware
officials the efficiency so err the idea
is to encode logical qubits in a
subspace of one or a few physical
systems but really try to exploit our
understanding of the underlying hardware
what is the error model for this for the
for hardware and how can we tailor the
code such as to take advantage of this
error model with a goal of course of
reducing the overhead in qubits and
gates and measurements ok so now that we
have this in mind this goal of achieving
our very efficient quantum error
correction with super 19 quantum
processors let's go back to such a
processor and look at the different
components and what is the error model
for these components but when we do the
best component to use as a carrier of
quantum information so let's first look
at the transpose so what are the errors
that occurs and pranced months but i've
already mentioned this you have
relaxation characterized by this Sigma
minus operator and then the time scales
are given here something like a few tens
to a few hundred microseconds and
there's phase errors with time scales
which are linked
to the t1 times so there's two types of
Arabs and the time scales are at best
hundred microsecond or so we can also
encode quantum information in the
electronic field is cavity in photons
there is a criticality and that's it in
that case what is the error mechanism
but it's a simple error mechanism it's
simply the loss of photons lots of a
single photon whatever time that's
characterized by the operator K which
removes the photo from the cavity and
the time scale for this for high-quality
kaneki's can be very large but even
larger than a millisecond so what we're
learning from this is that the cavity in
cavity QED as the simplest error model
to a very large extent there's a single
error channel a single photon loss and
it's quality factor is higher than that
of trans modes and so that's suggest
that maybe we should think of a quad for
information in that degree of freedom
rather than directly in the tracks month
and that's really this idea of encoding
qubits in theaters Alexander the first
idea is Alexander there's a small
question which maybe can be dealt with
quickly it was already though two slides
ago you use the phrase exponential
suppression of errors I guess and the
question
quite reasonable for mathematical
Institute is exponential in what maybe
the answer is you'll get to that or to
become clear in yeah that should be fine
so so thank you for don't hesitate to it
Rodney that's great thank you thank you
for the question so the as I was saying
so there's a general idea of a very
efficient encoding of qubits in a
theater and this idea really started
again in the early 2000s that press kill
Kiev which will use the GEEP code which
was has been realized since and try and
end security cubits all the types of
codes are the binomial codes and in
Korean state based codes are a cap
state-based codes and for those that are
interested in hearing more about that
you can consult a nice review by
whatever the conference organizers and
today I will focus on Korean state-based
oh sorry cap state codes I said I
reviewed that maybe not everyone is
familiar with coherent States and
especially Qin states of the microwave
field and so for the physicists that
will be of course well known but this
presentation so to explain this concept
I will use what some will take is a bit
of a silly example but I think that the
city example works well and so this is
my example so this is a very familiar
object the turkey in the microwave for
the microwave itself and so by looking
at this we can understand exactly I
think what I mean by cadet stasis a
microwave field
why well here you have microwave cavity
which I represented before by these two
mirrors but now is this just a kg of
your oven and rather than putting qubits
in this cavity we put turkeys well maybe
I don't do that but maybe I practically
according to this picture some people do
that and here you have a source okay
which you use to inject
microwave microwave field it's like a TV
and so if there was no food no no no
turkey you would get some amplitude of
the field but of course some of that
amplitude is being dissipated by the
soil and dissipated by by the food and
that leads to a lower amplitude okay so
what we know now is that the amplitude
is an effort that the amplitude of the
field is an important characteristic of
the field my fellow colonists again
there's a second important number and
that's the face so what we know is that
of course the there aren't cold spots
when we cook food in the microwave
that's why there are these turntables to
avoid it's called spot to the other same
place and that cold spot is simply a
manifestation of the fact that the feel
and microphone or even as a well-defined
face and as a result point where there's
simply no amplitudes no power of the
field and so rather than turning the
turkey Rob what you could imagine doing
is changing this fence and so if you
could move these things around well you
would have you would move your your cold
spots and therefore quickly turkey
appears and so now we have two numbers
to characterize the field the amplitude
and the phase that's what we call a
coherent state a coherent state is a
state of the eclectic field which has a
well-defined amplitude and a
well-defined things and this I can write
in terms of real and imaginary parts X
plus I key which we call quadratures and
are sometimes called a human microwave
engineering and generally we call this
alpha alpha being a complex number now
this is great I can plot this coherence
like in the XT plane in the quadrature
plane and so of course if the microwave
oven is off I just have a blob in the
center of phase space of this quadrature
space now as I turn on the microwave
oven there's some power that's being
built up now I assume the face to be
zero just for simplicity and as the food
is absorbed that power is lowered and
what we see here is that the point where
this coin set will stabilize is the
result of a competition between two
things how much power are you putting in
and how much data being is there and the
ratio between these two quantities will
tell you exactly where this Quin state
end up okay so what we've learned is
that we can stabilize quavered States by
opposing two things my very power and
that'd be great but what I would really
like to do now is include quantum
information in the East
coherent States and
like to call this the qubit state zero
the alpha state the state on the right
and I would like to call one the logical
state one the state with the same
amplitude but opposite face minus alpha
of course now what that means is that I
need to prepare superposition of 0 and
alpha and using that being doesn't sound
like the best idea and so what I'm
really looking for now is for a way to
stabilize coherent States without using
damping I will need two opposed to to
have this kind of a position between two
forces but it should not be dumping in
something else ok so we will come to
that two slides how can we stabilize
coherent States and in fact
superposition of coherent States which
we call cap States we're not using that
beam ok so I hope that this example was
clear enough and sorry for the turkey
before moving on to actually study lies
these days I think it's useful to again
think about why is it that we want once
we use these States and what is
interesting about these states so there
are two properties are these states
which I did which are in the box here
which are crucial the first is that
these two states are not quite
orthogonal they are in fact quasi
orthogonal and so that means that for a
large enough alpha they are I will
compare them to be orthogonal enough and
then for this reason we can encode
quantum information between minus alpha
as 0 and 1 because the overlap between
these two states it is in fact very
small exponentially small the second
crucial property is that kuririn snakes
are eigenstates of a remember a was the
photon loss operator acting on a cavity
with a removes a photon and a and that
was the main error mechanism remember
for a photon and so what we're learning
now is that acting on a on a query at
state leaves almost a trivial I mean
doesn't
changed essentially that state that's
actually that's very good news the Manor
mechanism of it as a very simple action
on our logical states okay that means
that I can encode some qubit this block
sphere where I'm going to declare the
zero and want to be the North Pole and
the South Pole of this of this deluxe
view and what I would like to do is of
course avoid any transitions between
zero and one I would like to avoid it
flips and this is the exponential
separation that's why that's one example
of an extranet exponential separation I
can compute the rate one over T one for
these bit flips and I can compute this
using the so-called golden rule if
you're not familiar with that that
doesn't really matter what is important
is that you need to compute this
expectation value and you find that this
explanation expectation value decreases
exponentially with the size of alpha
okay and so if you make alpha large
enough you can make you can make the bit
flip rate essentially vanish this is
great news if for large enough alpha we
have a qubit which doesn't flip or there
is no free lunch
of course here this is not adequate
America tako this is just a qubit and so
of course that cannot protect against
all errors yeah I would really like also
to be able to prepare a superposition of
these plus and minus alpha state of 0
and 1 which are again cap States and so
I need to look at what is the rate of
phase flips 1 over t2 and in that cases
the the conclusion is not so good
while t1 was going down especially fast
with the size of the cap of flask where
we find that the phase flip rate
increases with the size of the cap with
the size of alpha so that could be seen
as bad news but the good thing is that
well this is going down exponentially
fast this is only increasing slowly in
the polymer
matter and so what this means is that we
have a qubit which has a - error model
bit flips are extremely unlikely but we
will have to deal with facelifts ok so
now I can really take a lot of different
types of according where I thought I
have to correct for all type of errors
this is extremely unlikely I only have
to focus on this and because this one is
only increasing slowly as this one is is
going down exponentially
I can always okay and that's the
situation that I would like now to
explore but first we have to understand
how it is possible it's so we're gonna
think quantum circuits to prepare these
interesting States I've already said
that we can prepare these interesting
states by by opposing microwave power at
that thing but this is not what we're
about to do here we want to use
something else so now let me jump a
little bit under the physics a little
bit more of these microwave circuits so
there'll be two Amazonians on the slide
but will be mostly done with and onions
after that so the physics i would like
to explore is the physics of what we'll
call stabilize curry cats that name will
be justified in a minute so the main the
main player here is of course a
microwave cavity which I represent since
the beginning as two mirrors that are
facing each other but in practice they
may look something like this some of you
are more familiar maybe with 2d type
transmission line resonators that's
another approach to realize resonators
in for microwave photons but this is
simply a block of aluminum which has
been cut in half
machine such as to create all there and
if you bring these two pieces together
you have cavity in the middle which is
heyou centimeter by a few centimeter and
these way maths corresponds to microwave
frequency so you can
or microwave photons for up to a minute
ago or more in these cavities so
extremely high quality factor cavities
and these connectors here they could
these coax cable connectors essentially
are used to input microwave power and
collect the micro microwave power that
comes up for example for a QB duct okay
so before sterilizing Kirk at sometimes
like cats
it's worked looking again at the same
old civilization of a single single
coherent States we're not any turkeys
here so what we have without any
microwave power in the corner to play in
interface space we have the coherent
state representing vacuum and the center
of phase space now if I inject some
power and we all as I explained before
this place this field up to some value
that I've chosen here to be alpha equals
to again this is a competition between
microwave power I did put in that P if I
change the phase of the microwave field
I can stabilize minus alpha equals two
and so what is the iminium that
corresponds to this this is it that's a
simple enough amazonian where the first
term gives me the Newtonian of the free
ket Omega R as a frequency of the cavity
Nigeria counts the number of microwave
photons or photons indicated this is
just the energy of the cavity and that
time represents the drive so for those
who don't like I'm Italian so much
there's a nice convenient way to draw
these a Newtonian something which is
called a meta potential that's quite
useful because I can simply draw what
this image it looks like and I can
interpret this without potential usually
quite easy so this meta potential is
obtained simply by replacing a by the
operator by a complex number X plus IP
and a tiger therefore by X minus IP and
then the Amazonian H now becomes what
I'll call the meta potential H of X and
P and I can plot this meta potential
as a function of XMP here I'm plotting
this at a cut at P equals zero and what
you see is a straight line okay not so
interesting but what that means is that
if I start at x equals zero to the
vacuum state I'll represent by this ball
which is sitting at x equals zero
but this ball will just roll down the
potential and the slope of this of this
potential is simply given by the single
photon drive strength the more the
higher the drive step the microwave
amplitude the more this slope becomes
and again there's a contracting force
with a single photon dose which you will
lead to stabilization at some point okay
so that's easy you know if I open it up
with this potential but this is not what
I wanted to to get to study lies about
to say that I spoke alpha and minus
alpha so really the potential that I
walked should look something like this
if because if I start with a ball at x
equals zero it will roll down and a
quantum superposition of both atoms
therefore preparing and stabilizing the
cat state this is what I would be Dewald
and so it might opinion one of the
amazing things with superconducting
quantum circuits is that I can draw them
at a potential I'm at a potential like
this and I would really like to achieve
and then I can figure out what I meant
onion corresponds to that make a
potential and then I can say like okay
well what is the device that corresponds
to that in the lab that corresponds to
that meta to that Hamiltonian and the
amazing thing is that these mappings are
very accurate
the mathematical to DM Etonians of
course exact but from the device a
tomato onion to the actual device in the
lab we have a very good understanding of
that and once the device is realized it
really is extremely well captured by the
device lutonium that we really
understand so this is an exercise that
we can do and so we can say like okay so
what is the median behind this meta
potential furgus we will need some
non-linearity that shouldn't be too
surprised
in Kentucky between need and not a
everythi that we need is known as a
curve than the led hence the name career
cut and it takes this value mid K is a
constant and that's extremely easy to
realize in super not a quantum circuit
because that's essentially the I'm
Italian of a Travis Mon qubit and so
what I'm saying here is that in this
Kennedy we will add a transman keep it a
single transform like object that
transmog
will not be use to encode quantum
information its role is only to give a
little bit of nothing every team of Kerr
non-linearity to the field
okay that's important information will
be encoded in the field not the qubit
the qubit is only there as a spectator
to give a little bit of that ii turner i
need to obtain exactly the meta
potential to try to is something which
is called a two photon drive to photo op
and that's again something which is
quite very standard in assuming I think
quantum circuit in fact that to this
type of two photon bomb so what I use to
operate what I know parametric
amplifiers which are use in every
experiments and so why is it called a
two photon pump well because of this
square it adds two photons at the time
okay and so when I fight in this I met
Tony on is that the value alpha that
will be stabilized it is given by this
ratio it's this competition now between
two things again but rather than pump
power
damping it's a pump power over turn on
the area so with this we know how to
stabilize cat States
completely in a completely this
efficient less weight it will also be
useful a little bit later to look at the
full meta potential corresponding to the
semi tone Ian rather than taking a line
cut at P equals zero it will be useful
to look at the flow method potential
which looks like this before I gave you
earlier live here at equals zero what
I'm showing now is the full Matta
potential okay and so what we see is
these two wells and the saddle point in
the middle as we expected okay and so
again we will study lies States oh very
good skip this okay so that's the
physics of some you guys carry cats I
hope also that this picture with this
meta potential will this picture with
this mental potential will give you a
little bit more intuition also for why
bit flips are difficult why he flips are
unlikely because here you would really
have to go over this large potential
well for a big event to occur that would
be a very drastic event and so there is
really some there is really very good
protection against but again there was
no protection again face tips so these
ideas which were which were first
introduced in 27 which shorty curry I've
since been realizing the group of
Michelle the way yeah by agreement
colleagues and for a moderate size of
cats for alpha 1.6 they've been able to
show this concept of era bias with a key
wanna so I just hundred micro second T
two of 2.5 microsecond
so we're really happy to see that these
ideas are now exist also in the
laboratory the very similar ideas were
also explored very successfully by the
group of cyclic das at the NS in Paris
although here they use a different
protocol which in fact use dissipation
to stabilize a cat's with different
approach but again for similar sized
cats they were also able to show this
very large error bias so these are ideas
are very well are
good control board theoretically and
experimentally okay so very good so now
we have these stabilizer cat qubits and
the next step is to do something
interesting with these qubits we would
like now to do some quantum computation
and we'd like to think of course about
quantum error correction because this is
all might reduce this idea of saying
like okay can we exploit our
understanding of the underlying hardware
to arrive to achieve some form of our
very efficient quantum error correction
and now when we have our qubits that
exhibit strong noise bias and this is
what we would like to exploit and these
ideas have been studied theoretically it
before in particular by Anna Faris and
Chris Kael there are some names that
seem to be recurrent names in my my talk
some others that seem to be recurring
authors in my talk
and so what affairs and press Q F shown
was that noise asymmetry can be used to
increase the accuracy threshold of
quantum error correcting codes so that's
a very excellent news we can use bias
noise qubits to increase thresholds and
that was made more concrete in the
particular case of the surface code by
taking part in a more recently when they
show that the error threshold can be as
large as 28% for realistic bias noise
ratios so that's quite exciting and we
hope to be able to use this with these
cat state qubits but there is air a very
important question and that question was
addressed already in this paper is is
the noise bias preserved during
computation and so that let's look at
control nut games so what we have so far
our
qubits which in their idle state error
model which is biased but I really would
like this
biased model to be preserved by the
computation
and so let's look at another control not
Jade and let's look at an area arriving
before okay before the gate and so let's
say us that ever so as that era we know
will propagate to to Z errors that
wasn't it
of course that's bad news there is a
propagation of error but for this
particular talking quite happy because
when I see when I see is that the every
bias has not been undone as error
propagates to us an error that's we're
happy with this however if you look at
the operation of the gate what you
realize is that if the error occurs
during the gate things like that so
simple the Zener will propagate to an X
error and that's my news you've unbias a
noise and all of these ideas do not
apply anymore at least if you want to
apply control that and in fact what was
shown more recently by a griot and you
in MIT is that the scene at gate cannot
be performed in a bias preserving manner
with two-level systems and it seems that
we're in trouble here but the situation
is more positive for cur cats because
cats are not two-level systems we can
exploit the fact that these Kirkuk
humans have a ritual with space than
simply two levels to realize a synapse
in a bias preserving manner okay
and so this is what I would like to look
at in this slide
so the see that is a little bit involved
I'll come back to that in a second so
rather than looking at the sea not
trying to understand how this is
realized in the vise preserving manner
let me rather focus on the nut gate
which is as essentially the same physics
would have the same problem as the the
Cena but since there's a single qubit it
would be easier to understand and of
course in a not gate what I want is to
flip 0 to 1 I would like to do something
like this for example I could imagine
using a displacement operator to to flip
0 to 1 but that's not going to happen
with these
stabilize Crick a cubits because of this
draw protection against t1 errors which
also prevents us to flip the cuvette so
easy this is where the structure of the
Elbert space becomes interesting because
if you look at this space space we can
use much more of this Elbert space to
start a new operation we can do
something like this for example we can
go around in phase space to reach to
bring 0 to 1 and 1 to 0 and so we can
realize this in the bias preserving
matter in fact and that is because we're
not restricted to only two levels before
other side of thing or at least giving
an intuition of how this is in fact is
preserving let me say how this is done
in the lab how do we move these these
these blobs around and that's quite
simpler than facts so this is the
amazonian that we had before this one we
won't touch this is this is fixed by the
transform that we've embedded with the
cavity over this two photon Drive is
controlled by these microphones and this
we have complete flexibility there what
we can do for example is change the
phase of that tone and time and changing
the phase of that tone and time if we do
that slowly enough when the fact do
exactly this it will carry the coherent
state around the origin as I drew there
in this way allowing us to do it that
gate and so now I'd like to give you
some intuition for why this is bias
preserving we can write equations for
this but I hope that this meant a
potential release gives you the basic
understanding and so again this is the
meta potential where we store for
example a plus alpha state corresponding
to R 0 state here on the right hand side
well and so by changing the phase of the
drive what we're doing is that we are
changing
the axis here of stabilization and
rotating it in a way which is which is
phase dependent
okay so we're rotating the axis of
civilization such that effectively the
potential in time looks something like
this so it's rotating and if we are
rotating slowly enough well we will
carry that coherent state from zero to
one and back if we want and why is that
biased preserving but I hope that you
accepted that it was vice president at
this point because it's very unlikely to
jump over that big potential well that
large potential was there everywhere
respective of where was there all the
time as we rotated the the potential so
that the buyers presenting nature was
carried throughout the operation of the
lab gate this is why intuitively oh this
is a bias preserving operation of course
you can be more formal and add some
equations to that so that was the not
gate but now we have to look at the
scene of gate and this is where it
become much more involved because now
what we need is of course one cap to
rotate respectively on the state of the
other cap and so for this we need
multiple cavities something which is
routing it now which is now written done
where it becomes a little bit more maybe
frightening is when we look at the
ammeter M that is required to do that
but let me tell ya although it's large
and I won't go through all of that
that's not the goal is well under
control and we know that M Etonian is in
fact build of simpler pieces one piece
which corresponds to stabilizing the
control qubit when piece which is
composed of stabilizing the target qubit
and doing the rotation and one piece
which is there to correct extra errors
extra-firm accumulation of phase that we
don't want as we
do decades but the important point is
that we have an Emmitt onion for
something like this and what I try to
convince you earlier is that when we
have a mint onion we also have devices
so we have also a device which
corresponds to the tonight onion and
although this has not been realized he's
reported this has been realized in the
laboratory there's no reason to believe
that this cannot be done and so for this
time arriving at my conclusion so I mean
I think super I think quantum circuits
are providing platform for quantum
computation we've seen this this week
and there are avenues I think for think
a thinking it for the future we can
break this platform through the next
challenge is quantum error correction
and we need for that better qubits and
better codes this idea are very
efficient quantum error correction where
we develop develop qubits and codes
together I think is very powerful and
it's now getting more traction in the
field of course so two interesting
candidates the other transplants are the
zero by qubit and these stimuli straight
caps and both have been experimentally
demonstrated and personally I'm looking
forward to see you as an extent these
bias preserving scenic gates in the if
you're interested here are some of the
papers that contain the results that
I've presented so with that thank you ok
Thank You Alexandra so I think we can
begin questions with the quite a pointed
question in the QA I can read it out
there where you can read it yourself but
it says why do you think Kirk at qubits
and other proposals have not made more
progress at the system's level and what
needs to happen to displace the trans
Mons dominance and keep the community's
efforts from being too focused too early
this is the opinion of mr. anonymous
attendee ok
thank you for the question so why has
that there's been I mean I wear let's
look back at the history of the field my
when transplant were introduced we did
not try to be out of 50 transplants
right away for several years we try to
be able one transplant to transform
eventually three right and this is the
approach which is being followed now
with his novel qubit but I think this is
the right approach the fact that it is
not OB I in the trans man doesn't mean
that they die they will be behind the
transport in the future right as we
learn more and more about these qubits
we can start to integrate them in larger
larger devices and I will say that both
of the time qubits not the stabiliser
calculus that I've talked about
specifically made being shown for
example to reach and exceed a little bit
the error threshold for quantum error
correction something which has not been
done yet with the transplant okay of
course that needs only two of these
bosonic qubits but still in some respect
they are more advanced a transman so
what will win the race it's not clear
and for sure the transform we can
extract more jumps at the red spot right
maybe defense one is enough maybe
there'll be some more and more
discoveries improvement that will bring
the transplant to the next level but I
think what at the point that I want to
make in this talk is that it might be
too early to choose a winner I think
it's still time to explore multiple
options
and I ask a follow-up question on that
of course I really like that onion yeah
and what I was gonna say is you know I
agree this is interesting I agree we
have to look at systems but one of the
things that I find is really strange
about this which you did in your talk is
you discussed the improvement of say t1
and t2 versus time the real system
figure of Merit is T gate over T 92 and
many bits kind of neutrino eyes
themselves so it's hardly made gates
it's hard to couple together and what I
will say is it's just a complicated
issue but I think more about system
metrics then you know new qubit great t1
t2 is clearly that's not the whole story
and you know this my goal of my
presenting this particular plot of t1
and t2 is first I have easy access to
these numbers I think it's restating
as we learned more and more about these
other qubits
we are able to discussions yeah and for
example in the cat States I like to know
what's the equivalent day time okay and
you know maybe the T ones and can be
good or whatever well there's a lot of
research but you know I need to know
kind of more citrox about these better
in this paper which will have some of
this information and
I mean the next time at all paper by
anagram also you will see the gate I to
do but always remember that these
experiments are first-rate as it shows
we should yeah maybe I could say
something for example I mean I agree
also with the point that John makes it
you know for example if you look at the
Chicopee qubit which is in many ways
very beautiful if you say I do a single
qubit gates on that qubit it's not so
easy right compared to a trans mom it's
it's it's all harder so you gain
something then you may also lose
something and I think the jury's still
out what we're we just have to do it and
Emma just just to kind of reiterate this
I think it's really interesting right
now to compare qubits from a system
point of view in that you have a
protected to bit but then you have to
work harder on the gates and getting
them fast or do you have an unpredicted
qubit like the transmen we're a
screening easier to do the gates and I
don't know the answer I just think it's
really the people are looking at that
but then we have to report those numbers
to make sure that we know how to do in
the first experiment I would suggest
these are excellent questions to come
back to in the panel discussion the
wrap-up panel I'd like to maybe give one
more chance to a different and more
mathematical question but we should then
wrap up anonymous attendee also asks is
using the word superposition really apt
for the meta potential ball and that's
all amplify on that question what is a
matter potential I think you
to find it but it's not something you
use in a Schrodinger equation and is
there actually a rigorous use of the
meta potential for solving quantum
dynamics I really use this will give me
intuition for example these menus very
successful need to understand the
physics of bifurcation dynamics vacation
active fires
jTA's so they have real value to
understand what's going on my pigment
for example has been pushing these ideas
for many years to the question of super
positions
yes truly there is no doubt that we are
position and this has been demonstrated
clearly by the experiments so there is
no question no doubt there although the
metaphor that's all at least to me is to
give the other side my squaring on the
physics is clear we are preparing a
superposition of current states and in
fact if you don't like or comfortable
with any audience if my okay it seems
like there is like okay I'm not sure
that I will not be very useful but there
was an additional I mean Tony on that I
didn't talk about which was shown in the
slide where you would I think be more
convinced I think I'm looking at this an
Italian will be convinced immediately
that indeed
simple position there's a simple
factorization of their Kirk at an
opinion that should be quite sweet EF
also okay if you would care to that's a
question sitting in the Q&A and there
are several others why don't you if you
wouldn't mind look at those in the
coming minutes but I would like to
adjourn now and to thank you again for
your talk we will take a few minute
break and mainly for technical reasons
recording goes off recording goes on and
will resume in three or four minutes